tonight's Oscars ceremony will follow a
particular order that tracks the
filmmaking process itself so we begin
our presentation at the place where
every great movie begins with a story
that simply had to be told
writers we know that you are the true
backbone of the industry and we love you
for it
we also think you're all extremely hot
a writer wrote that
here are this year's highly original
nominees for Best Original Screenplay
Straight Outta Compton screenplay by
Jonathan Herrmann and Andrea Bella story
by Ashley savage and alum when Chris and
Andrea Birla bridge of spies written by
Matt Charman and Ethan Coen and Joel
Coen ex machina written by Alex garland
spotlight written by Josh singer and Tom
McCarthy inside out
screenplay by Pete docter Meg LaFave
Josh Bowie original story by Pete docter
Ronnie Coleman and the Oscar goes to
spotlight
this is the first Oscar for Josh singer
at Tom McCarthy this is the third
nomination for Tom McCarthy who is also
nominated for directing spot
we've got a thang open road we've got to
thank participant we've got to thank our
wonderful producers micro sugar
Nicole Rockland Blythe Steve Golan we've
got to thank our wonderful cast and crew
from Boston and Toronto my wife who Lara
Dave makes me a better writer every day
and makes me a better human every day
and my father Bruce singer who taught me
how to dream
thank you very much Academy we made this
film for all the journalists who have
and continue to hold the powerful
accountable and for the survivors whose
courage and will to overcome is really
an inspiration at all we have to do make
sure this never happens again
- Rhonda price the Gersh agency Andrew
Hurwitz to my beautiful wife Wendy Nora
Vivian my family and all our friends we
thank you this one's for you Gino we
love you love you mama daddy